check your watches time as always for
the press preview our first look at the
front pages
as they arrive in our inbox uh over the
remainder of they are we'll be taking a
look at what's making the headlines with
paulie mckenzie
director of the demos think tank and pr
consultant alex
dean but first let's run you through the
front pages that we have thus far
starting with the daily mail it reports
that princess diana's brother
al spencer has written to the mets to
ask they
investigate the bbc over her interview
with martin beshear
a new board could be set up to oversee
the organization's editorial output in
the wake of the scandal according
to the telegraph or with the guardian
talking to a former chair of the bbc
trust who warns against a feeding frenzy
over the diana report
never again bbc warned after scandal
that's the yorkshire post's look at the
prime minister's message
to the broadcaster uh
we've got the telegraph there their
headline bbc faces
shake up in wake of the bashir run i
think we did that one once before
our prince harry opens up about his
mental health in an interview with oprah
winfrey again
on the front page of the times
oh brother more on that princely rift in
the sun
now while the express says prince harry
is hurting the royal family to the core
interesting take that's a reaction to
his latest
tv appearance in a new series about
mental health
boom the star has a similar take i think
families returning from holidays in
amberless countries may not be fined if
children miss
school due to quarantine according to
the eye
in the ft the chief executive of
astrazeneca
has defended the company's covid19
vaccine for the first time since the
emergence
of rare fatal side effects calling its
critics
armchair generals hmm
interesting that one uh tonight as you
can see we are joined by paula mckenzie
and
alex dean lovely to see you both it has
been a while um so let's get dive
straight on into and paulie let's let's
turn to you first because
alex was so rude to me on social media
earlier this evening
um starting with the daily telegraph and
of course people are looking to continue
the story they are looking for ways in
which to develop the story they're
choosing to do so
uh by talking about potential changes to
the governance of the bbc
but by any token the response from the
bbc
needs to be robust to dyson doesn't it
absolutely does and
you know the the details which are now
clear
though they've been discussed and
rumored for a very long time
about the way martin bashir secured that
interview and
and built the confidence of diana in him
by
undermining her confidence in the people
around her
it clearly completely unacceptable
the worst kind of journalism
absolutely must not happen again at the
bbc or or
elsewhere what i fear though is that
whilst this
these events were very serious and there
was
uh for a kind of sustained period
afterwards a sort of a cover-up and a
wish to
sort of not talk about it not not admit
any faults
it for me it feels really quite
irrelevant
to and i'm sure alex is going to
disagree with me but pretty irrelevant
to this wider question of
what is the role of our national
broadcaster you know we're talking about
something that happened in
1995 you know alex and i were still at
school
as i think were you i had neil yes i i
certainly was thanks very much cheers
yeah
baby's behavior then it could be
an indication that uh the bbc is
dreadful now it could be an indication
that bbc's brilliant now
it has almost no relation to an entirely
important
and legitimate question about how i
suppose i suppose paulie
i suppose probably the the the point
that people will mention
polly the point that people will mention
is that martin beshear was re-hired by
the organization in 2016.
alex well that's right polly's given the
case for the defense which the bbc is
offering
a long time ago different bbc now
lessons have been learned how many times
have we heard that
but i think you can draw a clear line
there's a clear pattern
um from this behavior and the cover up
at the bbc about it 25 years ago
to stuart hall sexual abuse and the
cover-up of that at the bbc
to jimmy savile's sexual abuse and the
cover-up of that at the bbc
to rolf harris's sexual abuse and the
cover-up of that to the bbc
to re-employing martin beshear as you
rightly say this con man this liar who's
been exposed in this report
so much for claims it's historic to the
porkies they told about james dyson
for which they apologized this week how
much more of a clear pattern do you need
to have
if this were a tabloid newspaper it
would close
if this were a tabloid newspaper all the
hacked off lovies would be calling for
it to close
instead of rallying to the bbc's defense
the hypocrisy when it comes to the bbc
is unbelievable polly i i rudely
interrupted you so i'll let you carry on
with
the daily mail and their headline it's
al spencer repeating a call in fact that
he
that he made yesterday you know now
police must probe the bbc
now i suppose the problem with that is
the met are saying well
we need to find we'll look and see if
there's any new evidence most of the
stuff in this report i've got to say
despite james harding
former head of news over the bbc saying
that he didn't know anything
about you know he didn't know anything
about martin beshear's activities back
in the mid 90s
i knew about it it doesn't strike me
that there perhaps is
much in the way of of new evidence
no i mean of course it's right that the
the met should look over the report
look over the files evaluate whether
there is any new evidence
but it seems unlikely uh that that there
are going to be
there will be a sort of successful
police prosecution or or
proof of criminal activity here and of
course you know that
whilst i think it's it's right to say
that there is some
uh relationship between this and and the
tragic events of diana's death just two
years later
it's so much bigger than this interview
it's that you know as you've been saying
in your reports it's
uh the book that she uh collaborated uh
prince charles has done a
a documentary and done an interview
ex admitted to adultery there was
extraordinary press attention there was
the paparazzi who followed her
everywhere she went
it's there's so much that went wrong
in the exploitation of a vulnerable
young woman whose life was ruined and
ultimately destroyed
i think we shouldn't get sucked into
saying it was
all the bbc again alex is is right that
sometimes there can be hypocrisy
people who who want us to have a a
strong national broadcaster defending it
even when it's made
horrific mistakes there's also a lot of
hypocrisy on behalf of tabloid
uh newspapers who published and
persecuted this woman
now pretending that it's somehow all the
bbc's fault
oh well of course we your parents taught
you what two wrongs don't make
and i think that applies here um but of
course normally
and prince williams just told us that
this contributed to the paranoia that
dominated the end of his mother's life
normally people leap to the victim's
perspective and defense i mean bizarrely
and uniquely people
leap to defend the perpetrator when it's
the bbc
but neil to answer your question about
new evidence and and what could the
police inquiry do
i think there are probably at least
three things they can look at
the first is else earl spencer's notes
because i don't think they've actually
gone to the police before the second is
the account of the graphic designer who
was deceived by bashir
into doing this mock-up no fault of his
but then he got blackballed from the bbc
and never allowed to work for them again
disgraceful in its own right but the
third is that as we're seeing fall out
of the bbc
and people taking some kind of
responsibility and leaving
they may be more willing to give
accounts than they were at that time
because they're job dependent on it
so there should be a police
investigation and if you're a defender
of the bbc i would say you would really
want them to be investigated by the
police to clear the air over it
otherwise it would never be clear
we can accept we can accept your
position but at this and polly's at the
same time to an extent can't wait you
know
it may well be true the bbc certainly
has a lot to answer in all of this
now let's look at the front page of the
guardian fears of a bbc freedom
feeding frenzy over the diana report
there are those that are out there to
get the bbc
and that will use this as a lever to do
so to be perfectly honest
the bbc has spent more time beating
themselves up over this story
than any other broadcast channel that i
can mention
probably to their credit the point i was
seeking to make is that it's in the
bbc's own
best interest if they want to i mean i
think they shouldn't have their charter
renewed and i thought that before any of
this emerged anyway
so they will say oh well you're against
the institution your view doesn't count
but one's still entitled to express
dismay at a national broadcaster
behaving in this way and think it
reinforces the case for them not to have
their charter
but even if you're a bbc defender this
is my point neil
if unless they clear this up and unless
they answer these questions
the big issue for me will be the
question of if they will fit up the
security services
and those around our future head of
state with faked documents
and then cover that up for 25 years
who won't they fit up um polly i just
want to bring in
the front of the the chat of the edition
of the times and it's the picture of
harry
in the interview with with oprah winfrey
uh my pain over diana the headline there
i mean we've just been talking now this
has just been talking about the fact you
know we're talking about very
significant figures
in in public life but but we're also
talking about two young boys
that lost their mother at a really early
age and you know i think i'm probably as
guilty as anyone else of of forgetting
that they have had a lifetime
you know practically a lifetime without
their mother
reading all of these news reports
reading those books watching those
interviews
and i think perhaps it's understandable
that they want to hit back
i think it is understandable and i
thought uh prince william
and prince harry both gave moving and
compelling statements about
the the bashir interview and it's
important that
you know they who are also the victims
of this
awful tragedy that basically lasted the
whole of their mother's
adult life um are heard and
understood i think this the wider
exploration of harry
of his personal and private grief and
private anger at his father in public i
think
at some point he will come to regret i
think it is
immensely sad that somebody who who
basically has argued compellingly
that being a member of the royal family
is is too much it asks too much
of a flesh and blood human to be just a
cipher for the nation that you are
asked to ignore and suppress your
humanity
and to then inflict more of that pain
on that father who has to suppress his
humanity
to stand up for something for the nation
seems to me
unkind and an act of anger not of moving
on in the way that perhaps his therapist
might advise and also for he and megan
who experienced
her father talking about private matters
in public and they felt the grief of
that
that there are something that just are
are tragic and and need to be dealt with
but dealing with them publicly i i don't
think helps i think it's just immensely
immensely sad that he's doing this
to his father but also to himself still
alex and your answer will take us to the
break
i mean prince harry the megan situation
i mean
what did everyone think his first his
his thoughts would first go to
the first time he picked up a newspaper
and saw a story that he
either was or he felt was unfairly
critical of his then partner
yes i understand but i think that where
paulie and i agree
is that prince harry is lashing out
and he's very angry and we can all we've
all been in family situations where
we've felt that sort of anger and said
things we regret
it's just a matter of sadness i think
that in his circumstances
it gets played out across world media
and
that's especially um poignant when he
of all people has been calling for more
private life uh protection
rather than this kind of um exposure
which he's now willing upon himself
we will pause there briefly and join you
after the break uh when we'll be
discussing why
half-time holidays could be just a
little
happier for parents according
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of
gas being fired all around
[Music]
it is us absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's decisive victory
these students and now they're going to
be arrested
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
[Music]
uh welcome back to the press preview
paulie mckenzie alex dean
still with us and and a story that i
think will bring
a certain amount of cheer uh to a few
parents
myself included polly what's the story
on the front of the eye parents set
escape fines for halftime holidays well
there are
now a few countries that you can go to
they will let us in um over the halftime
holiday coming up here in a week or so
but you will have to quarantine on the
way back so basically what head teachers
are saying according to the eye
is that if you are quarantined
self-isolating after a foreign holiday
if you can book one they won't fine you
for not being able to send your kids
back to school for that week or or ten
days period
after the holiday which makes me regret
the fact that i have booked a camping
holiday in
england but never mind so i see i i
missed i mistook this story slightly i
i thought this was if you perhaps took a
couple of extra days took your child out
of school for a couple of days before
the beginning
of the of the halftime which i'm looking
at doing myself for it for a trip to
scotland
not quarantine i have to admit i'm
rather surprised by that you surprised
alex i'm not surprised i think it's
actually a sensible position and i'd
like to see a bit more of this
pragmatism from
government which of course has done the
right things in the vaccine program
world leading and the right things in
protecting us as a country
but we accepted all the restrictions
that we have in order to prevent
hospitals being overwhelmed
and we should be frank about the fact
that simply not a current risk anymore
coronavirus is now the ninth most common
cause of death in the uk it's two
percent of all
deaths that's not just behind things
like heart disease it's behind the flu
and the natural you know the case rate
nationally is stable
and declining a bit and of course
hospitalizations are still
falling so in my view we should be
pragmatic and we should
not just stick to the 21st of june
unlocking we should be bringing things
forward and freeing ourselves up
sooner we have endured great things
during lockdown
it's been for a great cause but there
has been a cost as well as a benefit
and it's time we became free the sooner
the better all this talk about holidays
and i just got a vision of alex dean and
speedo's dear
god right guys we will pause there